hey there folks as you may or may not be
aware earlier this year i published my
first fantasy novel called dreams of
fire and for reasons that
i don't really feel like getting into
right now i'm currently in possession of
a fairly large number
of this this is the market edition of
the book
and i kind of need to get rid of them
therefore i am currently offering these
up for ten dollars for both the book and
shipping only within the united states i
can't afford international shipping on
this normally this particular edition
would run you fifteen 15 on amazon so
we're talking about a 33 discount on
this keep in mind this is not the
illustrated edition it does have the
world map and the town map but other
illustrations are not present but if you
are interested in this and would like to
acquire it at a discount please reach
out to me council of geeks gmail.com and
uh will arrange for me to send this
right to you so thanks so much it would
be really helpful
i have no place to put these